bonjour mon nom et ma y à 34 à j'ai
failli mourir parce que je suis
asiatique
dans ma vie j'ai dû faire face à deux
longs combats le premier c'est le cancer
et le deuxième c'est un combat que j'ai
depuis l'âge très très jeune depuis
toute petite j'ai encore ce combat là
jusqu'à maintenant les gens prenant ce
mal mon nom et c'est pas compliqué parce
que c'est essentiellement trois lettres
une consonne deux voyelles
ou bien on le prononce maloubier on
l'écrit mal c est ma fille je sais c'est
mis ici mais on prononce mallet
normalement je corrige systématiquement
tous les jeunes qui déforme mon nom sauf
peut-être mais médecin parce que je me
garde quand même une petite gêne et est
normalement c'est quelque chose qui me
qui me tracasse plus de report tracassé
par l'opération parce que c'est vraiment
à cause du mois de mai et marie-mai qui
me donne vraiment une mauvaise
réputation pour mon nom est donc j'ai
vraiment eu une vie parfaite j'ai eu une
vie parfaite parce que j'étais
profondément heureux si j'étais en bonne
santé
j'avais rencontré l'amour de ma vie
j'avais une petite fille aussi de trois
ans dans ce summum de bonheur où j'ai
appris que j'étais enceinte de mon
deuxième enfant et au travail
j'étais au top de ma carrière en agence
de publicité qu'en et donc j'ai été à
l'hôpital pour voir si bébé numéro 2
tout allait bien et simple test de
routine de salm a révélé que toute ma
vie hop complètement basculé on a
diagnostiqué une leucémie cinq ans sable
et donc du jour au lendemain mais pour
vrai du
jour au lendemain à dire complètement
basculé le lundi j'ai appris que j'avais
une leucémie
le mercredi je me suis fait avorter le
vendredi j'ai reçu ma chimiothérapie en
isolement
c'était une leucémie aiguë donc ça veut
dire que c'est une leucémie agressive
donc il fallait vraiment commencer les
traitements de chimiothérapie le plus
rapidement en isolement donc je pouvais
pas sortir de ma petite chambre
d'hôpital pendant un minimum de six
semaines
donc tout ça est arrivé dans ma vie ça
complètement basculer ma vie pourtant
les médecins m'ont dit écoute mais on a
quand même une bonne nouvelle c'est un
cancer agressif
oui mais 70% du temps les cancéreux sont
capables de s'en sortir parce que la
chenille autre est vraiment bien le type
de cancer que tu as et g10 soixante dix
pour ça je ne sais pas pour vous mais
moi je suis bien très bien si moi je
connais un examen une note à la maison à
70% mais pas masquer titre et donc
c'était impensable pour moi de dire
acquis 70%
c'est un bon c'est un bon taux de survie
est donc j'ai dit à mes médecins pour
moi mais les médecins m'ont rassuré
écoute c'est un très bon taux de change
et des jeunes
tu es en forme normalement tu devrais
pas t'inquiéter pour ça parce que
normalement souvent avoir une réunion
les médecins avaient raison j'ai eu une
rémission trop courte parce que dix mois
plus tard la chose que je voulais pas
arriver est arrivé
une rechute une ruche ça a été le pire
moment de ma vie comme mon médecin m'a
dit mais ton cancer est revenu donc à
sakai revenus et ça m'a complètement
chamboulé parce que toute la chimio
l'avortement que j'avais fait servait
absolument à rien
les traitements de chimio était pas ses
efforts pour lutter contre le cancer les
cellules cancéreuses sont quand même
revenus
malgré tout et là on me dit écoute on
sort l'arsenal
il faut une greffe de cellules souches
pour pouvoir te guérir
et c'est quoi j'en avais jamais entendu
parler alors ce que les médecins me
disent c'est que le problème avec un
cancer du sein ou bien leucémie c'est
que la moelle osseuse qui se retrouvent
dans nos zones ne fonctionne pas bien et
à l'intérieur de ce que la moelle
osseuse
il y à des cellules souches les cellules
souches sont entre autres responsables
pour produire le système sanguin le
bulbe la globules rouges plaquettes et
j'avais vraiment besoin d'un donneur
on sortait parfaitement compatible avec
mon adn à moi alors ça revienne à voir
avec le sang une compatibilité du sang
est beaucoup plus facile
aller chercher qu'une compatibilité dos
des haines entre le patient et le
donneur et je me suis dit qu'est ce que
je fais à partir de maintenant
première option on va aller voir dans la
fratrie
j'ai un frère 25 % des cas le patient
peut trouver son bonheur à l'intérieur
d'une même famille donc d'aller tester
mon frère avec le meilleur taux de
survie possible
malheureusement mon frère n'est pas
compatible avec moi celui ci au numéro 2
donc solution numéro deux options numéro
deux en chute encore de tout survie
voilà il ya une possibilité de trouver
un donneur partout dans le monde
il ya un registre où il y à des donneurs
volontaires
il ya un bel 5 million de donneurs
volontaires qui sont prêts à donner
leurs cellules souches à une personne
qui ne connaissent pas et donc ça veut
dire que c'est une quête aussi une quête
internationale un patient à montréal
pour recevoir des donneurs un donneur de
cellules souches qui vient de
l'australie c'est possible parce que les
54 pays travaillent ensemble pour
trouver le donneur
chaque pays et recrutent
individuellement leurs propres donneurs
et une fois qu'on décide à l'honneur
dans un pays on est dans la base dans la
banque mondiale de donneurs et je me
suis dit bon bel 5 millions fait videur
que je veux trouver quelqu'un savait
quoi sur 25 millions n'y a aucune
personne qui est compatible avec moi
aucune personne compatible avec moi
parce qu'il ya un manque de diversité
mon ethnicité aller jouer dans ma
défaveur en termes de taux de survie
voyez vous il ya soixante dix pour cent
des donneurs au niveau mondial qui sont
des occasions des bleus est donc si un
malade a besoin d'une greffe de cellules
souches les chances qu'ils trouvent un
donneur sont dramatiquement beaucoup
plus élevés pour cette personne là que
pour moi ou pour autre personne qui sont
d'une autre origine ethnique
ça ça veut dire que puisque moi je suis
vietnamienne puisque mes compères
peuvent être médecins arabes noirs
vous avez moins de chances de trouver
votre donneur compatible
et en plus le vietnam n'a pas de
registre public de cellules souches
ça ça veut dire que trouver un donneur
vietnamiens fallait le trouver
rapidement parce que vous savez quoi
mondlane c'était deux mois pour trouver
en donnant deux mois pour trouver un
donneur
c'était impensable donc j'ai dit à mes
amis médecins tant qu'une campagne parce
que chan publicité je faire une campagne
mais c'était complètement absurde parce
que le moment où on me dit realistic
mans que j'aimais pas de donneurs sur
les 25 millions
j'étais revenu dans la chambre d'hôpital
en isolement
plus tu veux avec la chimio et donc
quand j'ai dit à mes médecins que
j'allais faire une campagne je peux déjà
imaginer leur réaction oui
c'était impensable mais ce que les
médecins savaient pas c'est que j'avais
une armée de gens qui m'aimait à
l'extérieur et la personne qui m'a
énormément aidé ne sous-estimez pas le
pouvoir de l'amitié du président
christiane perochon qui est une amie en
publicité aussi
et lorsque je lui ai dit puis ont pleuré
ensemble je lui ai dit trouve moins
d'honneur puis à le prix parce qu'à
voulais me sauver la vie le prix 7
cette demande l'appui elle a rallié tout
lundi ce qu'est la publicité les
journalistes et donc on a pu faire une
immense campagne grâce à elle grâce au
genre publicité grâce aux médias et oui
le public a embarqués parce que l'été
ça a été l'été de la campagne save my de
voix que vous avez peut-être vu et donc
j'étais à l'hôpital en isolement j'avais
des amis qui nous donnait des directives
ok ben and over canada et m suivi de 11
heures la presse suivi et donc moi je
donnais des entrevues à même ma petite
chambre d'hôpital
li médecins en zones ou ci travaillait
très fort parce qu'on a briefé les
médecins pour quel médecin encore passer
des entrevues
on avait soudainement plaint d' espaces
publicitaires qui nous ont été offertes
gratuitement on a une couverture
canadien n'en avait des autoroutes à
montréal vancouver toronto où il ya une
plus grande concentration de deux
vietnamiens et d'asiatiques et là
soudainement ça m'a donné une deuxième
chance que je me reprends mes acquis 12
et à la fin ça a été une campagne avec
des retombées médiatiques super
intéressant mais qu'est-ce qui a été le
plus intéressant c'est que je moi j'ai
une greffe deux mois plus tard j'ai une
greffe en octobre octobre 2014 et ce
n'est pas grâce à la campagne
j'ai eu une greffe de sang de cordon ça
c'était la troisième et dernière option
puisque je faisais seulement 50
1050 kg au pardon parce que ça qu'on dit
ça c'est vraiment pas bien
50 kg donc 110 livres il y avait juste
assez de cellules souches dans un stand
pendant pour me sauver la vie mais la
campagne a généré beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'impact il ya eu 25 mille
inscriptions durant cette année là
normalement et marc québec françois
combien d'inscription comme donneur de
cellules souches 3000 est allé chercher
25000 donneurs de cellules souches une
augmentation assez impressionnantes en
termes de données asiatiques aussi et
finalement eu trois vies de sauvées en
amérique du nord grâce à la campagne
donc deux personnes au canada une
personne aux états unis
les gens se sont ralliés les gens au
dessus c'était quoi un donneur de
cellules souches et il ya eu trois vies
de sauvées grâce à une campagne de
publicité la campagne simplement edwards
a été bien oui déjà été j'ai été très
chanceuse d'être parmi tant d'autres
mais j'étais chanceuse parce que je
faisais partie de l'industrie de la pub
donc oui on m'a aidé mais voyez les gens
qui sont sur la dia qu ici il ya dix
huit mille patients qui en fait
exactement la même chose que moi
dix huit mille patients qui ont pas
trouvé le donneur de cellules souches et
certains d'entre eux vont faire une
campagne vont aller solliciter les
médias avec des fois des bons résultats
d'autres fois non sachez que 50% d'entre
eux que vous voyez présentement sont
décédées sont décédées parce qu'on pas
réussi à trouver leurs donneurs de
cellules souches
donc la question qui tue comment fait on
pour devenir donneur de cellules souches
premièrement sachez que les critères de
chakra juste d'y faire un peu ici on est
au québec quand je vous parlais au
niveau du québec
la première chose que vous allez faire
c'est de vous inscrire au registre de
héma québec héma québec va vous envoyer
inquiète de frottis use
les pouvoirs vous soit baisse est un kit
de q tip frotter à l'intérieur de votre
votre joue de votre bouche pour
collecter les cellules et après c'est
envoyer au registre des mots québec qui
est relié au registre international
attention il faut être âgé entre 18 et
35 ans si vous avez trente six ans c'est
trop tard l'inscription pour être
donneur doit être en 18 et 35 ans vous
allez demeurer sur le registre jusqu'à
vous soit 200 temps vous êtes prêt à
sauver quelqu'un et si jamais on vous
appelle il ya une chance sur 9,5 à les
acheter une 6 49
ça vaut la peine si jamais vous êtes
appelé il ya deux façons de donner
première mort par prélèvement de sang
périphérie je fais 80 % et donc personne
connaît prélèvements de sang
périphérique est ce qui arrive c'est
qu'on va donner des de la médication
on va sur produire les cellules souches
dont vous allez avoir des injections
pendant cinq jours vous aller se
reproduire les cellules souches qui vont
sortir de votre moelle pour aller dans
votre sens et après on va collecter le
sang les laisser le souches de votre
sang telle assise par la 4 à 6 heures et
ensuite ce qui va arriver sur votre robe
laisser les souches qu'on a besoin d'un
bras et on va vous remettre le sens
qu'on n'a pas de besoin sur un autre
dans l'autre bras au fond et vous êtes
parfaitement conscient netflix
oui instagram et à qui vous faites des
salles fille parce que vous allez avoir
une auréole vous allez sauver la vie de
quelqu'un
ceci dans 80% des cas dans 20% des cas
15 à 20 % des cas c'est au bloc
opératoire dr vous endort oprean la
liste est le chouchou de votre moi le
directement puis on vous garde une nuit
en observation et ensuite vous êtes vous
pouvez rentrer à la maison
sachez que c'est le donneur qui choisit
quelle méthode qu'il préfère le médecin
peut suggérer une méthode plus qu'une
autre
sachez aussi que lorsque le méfait
demande une ponction par mois là
c'est probablement parce que votre
patient est un enfant est donc ce que
vous savez aussi ce que vous allez
rentrer à la maison puis la vie est
belle mais pour l'infirmière de déjà une
infirmière qui est là en même temps que
votre collecte de cellules souches et
qui prend le couleurs de cellules
souches qui prend deux avions cseries
dont internationale qui voit l'infusé
chez le patient et ça c'est quelque
chose de hyper important pour le patient
parce que le patient est en train de
décider au lieu déjà pratiquement pas ce
qu'on lui a déjà donné des la chimio et
de la radiothérapie qui sont
irréversibles votre don vraiment vont
lui donner une seconde chance et donc
quatre ans et demi plus tard ça fait
quatre ans et demi que je suis greffé
christiane et moi on s'est dit ça se
peut pas on peut pas laisser ta de
personnes malades qui n'ont pas de
donneur de cellules souches et que
personne n'était au courant qu est ce
que c est cette injustice là doit cesser
c'est pas parce que tu es noir bien que
des médecins ou plutôt les yeux [ __ ]
que t'as pas le droit d'avoir tu as
juste chances de guérir d'un cancer
alors il a fondé une fondation il ya
cinq mois on a froid dans une fondation
qui s'appelle soit bauer parce que soit
on veut vraiment soin d tous les gens
qui a incité les jeunes les 18 35 ans à
s'inscrire comme un donneur de cellules
souches
parce que ce qu'on dit c'est qu'elle a
un cancer égale combat égal tout le
monde devrait être au même stade par
salama personnes devraient être
discriminés par rapport à un cancer et
donc on a lancé une fondation puis la
fondation eu énormément date de nos amis
publicitaire encore et qu'est ce qu'on
fait notre but c'est de diversifier
justement le registre de donneurs de
cellules souches est ce qu'on fait on a
trois choses qu'on fait on dessine
plateforme en ligne
où les patients qui ont besoin d'un
donneur puis qui trouve pas dans
donneurs peuvent s'inscrire sur leur jeu
sur notre plateforme soit of the world
et tous les gens peuvent voir les vrais
patients présentement on a cinquante
patients et survivants ils sont sur
notre plateforme
ce sont des gens réels qui ont besoin de
donneurs et il ya aussi des témoignages
de survivants qui ont passé à travers
cette situation très difficile qui donne
aussi de l'espoir assez assez assez
malade et lorsque les malades et où les
survivants partage sur les réseaux
sociaux
il ya une possibilité aussi que les
donneurs plus voir cette personne témara
telle personne est malade et donc les
18000 vous allez pouvoir voir leur
visage
vous allez pouvoir voir leur histoire la
technologie c'est la première chose
qu'on fait la deuxième chose qu'on fait
on a d'excellents partenaires médias et
les partenaires médias nous donne aussi
de la visibilité pour les patients alors
donc oui vous allez voir des de
l'affichage ou des bannières sur sur les
autoroutes d'une campagne de caux ou
bien d'une banque mais vous allez aussi
bientôt voir des publicités pour les
patients par les cas réels où ils ont
besoin de donneurs de cellules souches
la troisième chose qu'on fait on fait
des conférences et des conférences dans
les écoles les universités et dans les
business souci parce qu'on veut
justement que les gens sachent c'est
quoi un donneur de cellules souches et
quant à moi comme je vous ai dit ça fait
quatre ans et demi
j'ose espérer que dans six mois je
rencontre mon médecin qui va pouvoir me
dire mais je suis guéri de son cancer
merci
[Applaudissements]